peu
[Musique]
on imagine en question par des mentors
[Applaudissements]
et
on est bon on y meurt après les
souvenirs
bah je vais pouvoir croiser à cette
époque là et
j'avais fait des chansons pour un os
plaques de cette époque là c'était noël
des champs ou grandes idoles de bayon
relie bird noël des champs
ces pierres
[Musique]
m
atlantique oui oui j'en mets tellement
steve cropper a non seulement pas trouvé
annoncé six frappeurs qui joue qui joue
à la guitare c'est pas ça me coûte
c'est pas trop tôt tu n'as c'est presque
bah oui ça me pique est il indiqué c'est
tout simple consommateur plus oui parce
qu'il y avait en même temps à belhout et
[Musique]
l'orchestration se souvient de cet album
où il y avait d'un côté des slows à être
coûteux voyage formidable c'est ça
exactement l'europe le dit il
j'aime beaucoup d'albums de neilson et
j'avais donc d'un album à l'autre il
faisait des plus totalement différent si
des fois avec des cordes
safran s'est produit vers un produit par
john boehner ouais c'est un peu tard une
année il y avait toujours des grands
musiciens effet deux grandes salles
basses et curial parce qu'il est pas et
pas très connue en france mais c'est
parfois inspirés de ses passages coq à
l'âne
il avait une voix incroyable et bien il
va il a fait tout un album aussi de
chansons de randy newman avec yellow man
2 1
bravo france suivant en ça c'est dur
mais c'est bien
[Musique]
on
l'autre
[Applaudissements]
camille
[Musique]
ouais bravo ça c'est très dur
produit par nick mason inc lors d'un
voyage qui était chez lui tu voyais les
paralytiques était chez lui dans sa cave
en train de trafiquer les sanctions sont
bizarres well superbe
je suis content que tu les trouves et ça
m'aurait fait s'appelle tu trouves pas
bravo aux suivants
déjà plus facile pour eux c'est pourquoi
ça tu vas connaître
tous les sons mardon
en
attends cc johnnie to kei cars born to
lose
j'aimais beaucoup un album acoustique de
dieu c'est le mythe du loser c'est le
fameux nick wey a way est ce que tous
les regards doivent être des losers
batch ou non bon voilà on continue
[Musique]
je souhaitais
je pense tout juste en or mais à
dubrulle tu brûles quand tu lis tout
juste eu brûle parce que sur cet album
il y avait beaucoup de musique avaient
été faites par quelqu'un d'autre et ça
c'est lui qui a fait la musique
[Musique]
le web qui dit pauvre est s'exprime
tentative maintenant mais c'est pas
facile mais tu as un bon ne met pas les
bruits facile c'est sixtine dans le
sport live et c'est pas beau week a fait
la musique mais c'est bien le tennis
tout juste parce que c'était son groupe
avant aux suivants ont fait quatre morts
ça ressemble s'assemble de m6 comment
s'est excusé les bases américaines
j'étais comme ça quand même
j'aurais bien voulu enregistrer cette
époque le reste un peu [ __ ] mais on
avait toujours le tracker ont joué
toujours très très vite le morceau je
crois qu'on a été punk avons beaucoup
mais tu sais pas l'expert mines puis je
suis tombé sur un conte un jour qui m'a
dit il faut que ce soit fort et rapide
cette année c'est vrai et pas voir pas
toujours jeu suivant en question
[Musique]
mais
c'est le message est oui
baldhead non
ces gens se pardonnent plus récents puis
bonnel ouais bravo c'est wayne des
parties j'avoue j'aime beaucoup car ils
ont bien ça serait très bien peuvent
réellement givré ouais mélange de pas
mal de musique entre des riffs rares des
rythmes blues aux fins c'est un des
trucs qui va le plus éclaté visuellement
et musicalement on les a eus dans bain
de minuit l'année dernière avec génieau
après zurich
bravo c'est darty boulevard lumumba qui
prouve pas ça qui va bien ou s'il va
très bien le lien il est tombé sur une
espèce de yoko ono du bronze mais il va
bien sergey brin co faire gaffe
elle tient on à johnny
ah ah
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
suivant le suivant hall est parti
son
c'est un harrison bravo tu sais quoi de
chine on a parlé de lui
d'une ado magna com comme on parle d'une
beatlemania notamment en suède elles
sont folles de vous en suède les pennons
web et ça fait deux ans qu'on n'y a pas
été ça au pérou ou alors là c'était un
enfer en a pas pu s éveille slovaque
anna qui dormait dans la neige qui y
dormaient dans la rue qui lécher les
vitrines qui vous envoyez des ours en
plus sur la scène pourrait y en a qui
dormait dans les armoires des chiens au
total c'est quoi le plus en plus fou
c'est dormir dans l'est dans les
armoires des chambres d'hôtel oui parce
que j'ai rarement les chambres sont
fermées avant quelques les et le patron
absolument ou alors ils sont montés par
les frères
ouais mais c'était quand même bizarre
chez tour ton armoire tu prends ton
oreiller et au niveau sexe au niveau
sexe
ouais mais je sais pas quand à 2000
suédoise de vente en hôtel qu'est ce que
tu fais rien je prends dix jours son
plus jeune on est sisi côté bébé ça t'es
sûr ah ouais vraiment vraiment sûr je
veux dire est ce qu'on peut dire c'est
15 ans ferme ses 12 ans avant tous les
mineurs ouais c'est ça mais sans tout
mineur c'est ça votre ancienne race
était mineure wes examinée j'ai compris
des services sociaux en parlant de vie
mais les aime bien mais justement libé
les aime bien et parce qu'en parlant de
vous et des rites là comme ça il disait
il ya des gens qui veulent le beurre et
l'argent du beurre c'est jeanne mas et
julien clerc dire qu'ils veulent à la
fois la thune salut les copains puis
valeur il sait pas ce que ça veut dire
qu'ils veulent en même temps être connus
avant la crédibilité soit tu veux pas
toi je sais même pas ce que c'est une
craie vientiane j'en ai strictement rien
à [ __ ] le beurre et l'argent du beurre
il se trouve que ça marche donc
effectivement tata du fric mais je vais
à jeanne mas il faudrait vraiment être
up voix ah ouais quand t'écoutes
effectivement son petit bébé rock la
semec fait en fait je veux dire j'ai
jamais fait un titre pareil quoi j'ai
fait le truc que j'ai envie de faire des
choses à me effectivement j'ai jamais
cherché à avoir une crédibilité quoi que
ce soit ça m'a toujours étonné que les
gens et disent ouais vous habiller bien
alors qu'on salue fâché tout comme tu
veux ouais vraiment coin j'ai donc voila
mon ami très bien merci monsieur nicolas
le suivant je supporte revers
ouais mais on les a fait venir au zénith
ouais je sais en première partie c'est
vrai tout à fait absolument vous aider
en gd nouveau allait corser un peu trop
vite et on leur coupe d'argent sont pas
tu vois pas ce que quand il fait les
premières parties nous on avait fait la
première partie de chez peak oil
orchestral manoeuvres avec de petits
amplis et où rien n'a qu'à pas jouer
chez vous aucune foi parce qu'il s'est
cassé la gueule sur scène ce sera autre
chose mais on n'a pas mis des pièges bon
allez le libé la chromé allez vas-y ses
derniers tubes salle à la géo car 10
l'ag de sage et aucun ni j'écoute la
radio un swell et aucuns disent tous
âges à part attend que ce pur et noir
désir je dise oui ce sont les plus dans
le look rouge elle est à toi tu arrêter
tout ça le ouais j'ai arrêté le rouge à
lèvres a effectivement pourquoi c'est ta
mère ma grand mère me dit récolter un
charmant garçon allez on continue bien
sûr
ça ça ressemble à toby odone mais c'est
c'est un truc vieux ça non justement ça
ressemble à des [ __ ] mais quel jeu
qu'autre chose là je m'adresse presse
michel choquet de jouer c'est france
c'est le groupe come back de
l'engagement je compte dans ma main
tracy g al iman ya même des gens qui ont
dit effectivement si on descend en
france après colette magny des rigolos
quand tu dis la musique véhicule à doit
véhiculer la révolution tu parle
sérieusement
ouais ouais parce que c'est vrai que
c'est
effectivement quand tu entends bab rocks
foot tu aimes ça tu fais plutôt quand
même dans l'aventuré dans l'exotisme que
nouvelle chômage et la misère quand même
n'aurait non parce que je vois pas
pourquoi je parlerai du chômage de la
misère alors qu'un déjà gt2 en chômage
mais j'ai pas vraiment regardé comment
tu vas aller la révolution suis parle
pas du chômage et de la misère
c'est une question devrait se réunir
dans un concert le 6 8 personnes et puis
leur envoyer quelques entretiens
qui sait pas vignes à savage j'te le dis
tout de suite
on va pouvoir hué quand même que deux
ailleurs l'ue
yala même caplovic le connais pas du
tout hervé paul hervé paul ii quand même
appréciable mais oui
[Applaudissements]
l'interaction végéter ouais alors donc
c'est la petite musique de match on la
voit bon je connais c'est un truc de
grèzes je garde ta terre à trouver parce
que tu as dit une fois que tu adorais se
compose de leurs deux matches de l'emi
en [ __ ] d'accord je vais faire buffet
alors c'est de faire arriver là ouais je
connais je mets normes et à tout en
temps mais je sais je sais trouver une à
trois qu'ils ont fait a dit une fois
voilà moi j'écoute décoché l'air et lui
les coacher leurs c'est mozart
non d'ailleurs trois b coachée l'air à
lui j'ai guéri trop [ __ ] il n'est pas
chez jean
il est passé leur dire c'est qu'ils
alors il s est pas chez crise et chez
deutsche grammophon sûrement oui
certainement mais c'est le genre ouais
je me la mets oui c'est ça vivaldi
villette
bravo je l'aimais je suis dès mercredi
[Musique]
sa maman est
il faut mettre un
[Musique]
m
doucet cheese magic diamond sur la coke
toyo l'acta thinon guadiola clame
jacques tati à monaco mister you take a
ride
c'est un métier d'ingénieur de visionner
me laisser 6000 tr/min
[Musique]
ouais à crête est ce qu il va aux siens
leur modèle
ces masters
après un petit temps yes we need is love
you like suivant
m
the beginning
[Musique]
investec kraft
[Applaudissements]
innover catherine est venu c'est un
combat entre des stars
alors qu'il n'a pas payé
eh ben
[Musique]
je le respecte
eyermann
toi sauvegarde
au camp final de son need you now
dix des dix à être green sur
guardian.co.uk
[Musique]
il est venu au bras du code
la victoire
[Musique]
ces troubles au sprint mind your me wade
et chris bosh et james whitey tard
qui est ce
[Musique]
mais la navette on web ils peuvent amer
ok
[Musique]
ouais
m
[Musique]
ok
[Applaudissements]
tandis que l'hiver ce ton vrai nom c'est
hervé forneri en es et tu t'ai appelé
dick rivers à cause d'un film d'elvis
exact qui s'appelle loving you ouais
alors j'ai posé une question quand même
une différence et laquelle le prénom
seddik d'aircal bravo tu vois déjà très
bien les chats sauvages
ça vient du groupe du père d'une
chanteuse ou là
ah ben ouais tu sais toi c'est quoi les
wildcats marty wild et les wildcats le
père de jim white
pour fêter ça les chats sauvages ça a
duré qu'un seul était quoi ça a duré
deux ans où vient donc ça va durer vingt
ans ouais ça a duré le premier disque on
l'a fait en avril 61 et je les ai
quittés en outre 62 pourquoi on
s'entendait plus très très forte
aujourd'hui que alain decaux du rock and
roll faut bien dire quand il paraît que
c'est l'âge d'or de la pop
l'âge d'or sa part à jour tout course
après 183 je suis très content de le
faire parce que la musique ça m'éclate
et puis hamburger campagnard et
recadrages ça c'est un bouquin qui est
sorti à deux ans qui a bien marché et là
je prépare un roman historique au rock'n
roll à ce nom roman 1 qui sortira en
même temps que double album que j'ai
fini guémy annoncer à la rentrée qui
sort fin août
quand dominique phare en toi tu es rtl
j'ai pas depuis des temps immémoriaux
ah ça c'est quoi 17 ans non j'ai fait la
première prestation gp ferrer tel 162
pour présenter les beatles appel aux
médias ou les coups mais je me suis
arrêté entre tournai et que donc la
chercher
vous avez envoyé venir ma nantais
directeur adjoint des programmes d'une
femme et services artistiques plus
lentement et sa grange n'a fait que
durer la musique ouais s'occupe de la
musique des jeux des jeux
ouais totalité journalistes enfin
toujours d'ailleurs ça s'oublie pas non
je ne suis plus vraiment j'enregistre il
a bossé pour match des usa c'est chose
du coin secondes
on va passer au jeu
[Musique]
enfin les compositeurs alors à old dogs
stand by me khan société giles rock à
bbb et on bloque je sais pas qui c'est
et même outil
les brestois bravo
stop
reach out i'll be there la marque de 10
noms les compositeurs pour
you can't hurry love tu connais pas tu
pars de chez spect'art la mairie corby
la d re regarder chez le patron de la
maison
non mais je doute les suprêmes tous les
fantômes
je connais que la vente de dire on y
disait le vice-ministre du thème des
armes
on continue avec les compositeurs tu es
prêt date ce rythme à elvis 54 ou happé
par la carte sur big boy crudup wade at
the same repris par lennon sur canal et
maints quartiers sur back in the ussr
way ans les producteurs mark lyall du
hall remember you can enjoy the ground
in stone karma my sweet lord suspects
bravo
à
quand tu sais que les producteurs plier
aux normes la halle des arts
les yes relax frankie goes to hollywood
video killed the radio star tu dois
connaître sa ville
oui c'est plein de morrison van morrison
légumes bravo peu les caries bravo
encore un peu plus les chansons homonyme
il ya une chanson qui s'appelle drive my
car dans yes we can le dernier album de
crosby david crosby 89 et l'autre il ya
baby loup qu'il va demain car davidson
sur canal baba ould bah tu sais le
revolver na
un missionnaire sai mais il a dit ce
qu'il a dit là bas sol comme tu as dit
déjà j'étais sur un album des beatles ou
d'un oui petit humain petit mot alors
toi tu connais ou oman par bernard web
mais si tu peux donner c'est un jour tu
as dit à paul mccartney
quelle est la chanson que tu as écrit
deux cas pas eu de succès il a décrit
pour peter and gardens à l'accord voici
pas poster ou mat
il ya une chanson homonyme par qui me
donne bravo nouvelle fantaisie
alors on va faire les one hit wonder
or si les mecs qu'on fait qu'un succès
dans leur vie à toi ma carter part bravo
quel est le seul tube connu d edwin
hawkins singh 69 des blues non
toi tu sais rapide et ouais nan vraiment
fait fort en parlant de repenser on va
faire un blind test d'adn aide sur le
rock français étaient prêts
[Musique]
le blind test tu peux les sorties tu
sais qu'il a relancé le papagayo de
saint tropez le corti barils à rien que
pour ça il mérite pas une médaille
ouais ça c'est ce qu'avait plus dur à
faire sur antenne 2 à côté c'est rien
relancer à il devrait te prendre comme
directeur général puis le sait ça
c'est argent trop cher voilà bravo à toi
si tu reconnais tout aux trois premières
mesures
c'est gagné alors j'ai entre cher
téléphone mais pour le lait c'est parce
qu'ils ont besoin de 40 secondes par les
droits d'auteur avant quand ans qui dit
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont besoin de 40
secondes pour les droits d'auteur
connaît son métier quand même le droit
savez la toa rock français est bien
ouais c'est moche c'est le début des
eighties fouet dans un téléphone c'est
c'était le point de repère d'une
génération parce que je voudrais pas
c'est qu'un autre téléphone parce que ce
que derrière il y en a beaucoup de
filles
il ya pas eu grand chose derrière un
téléphone n'y a pas eu grand chose ça
c'est taxi girl
oh la la c'est ce garçon way où tu peux
laisser un peu c'est bien c'est bien jay
jay and speed qui reconnaît tout comme
ça ou trois premières mesures aussi en
attaque si york facile je suis quand on
connait c'est ouais non c'est facile
parce que c'est cette une certaine
originalité à l'époque parce que
maintenant préface pas plus intéressant
mais je crois que c'est ça qui fait
qu'une musique intéressante c'est que
l'original
pas plaisir alexis bon suivant alors au
suivant la voie c'est starshooter
[Musique]
tekken wii ça c'est kent il n'y a pas de
problème le morceau
[Musique]
m
deuxième album ma vie c'est du souhait
que tu as un drop est partie des
supporters qui nous fait des cornes de
bataille la tête à rolex
moi j'ai ma rolex au delà
[Musique]
ça s'est marié les garçons ouais oui
mais alors le morceau
ça sèche on ne souffle pas va pas
commencer l'année on souffle ans
maintenant à non le morceau c'est
vachement plus dur je pense que je vais
chez l'amant multi très dur on a trouvé
des gens qui vient
c'est marié les garçons dans les pas de
problème
un morceau il le dira pas ba ba ont eu
un petit peu
seripop 2 sur une banquette dans le hall
de l'hôtel
laurabuc frère et deux sur une bande
détruits
tu
ça c'est les ablettes way
si tu verras c'est
un des plus beaux morceaux
qui a été repris par un groupe de
rock'n'roll vraiment de rock'n'roll
alors
le papagayo évasive près de plus en plus
dur voilà l'état reconnaît mano negra
mala vida
ouais bon
et ça c'est les [ __ ] dans le titre
petit peu pour eux
ouais voilà l'été voilà les faits
mais bien entendu certains voyaient va
vite bah ouais mais c'est monsieur roch
ces messieurs roxy reconnaît pas et qui
marqua
[Musique]
jardi sort de ces moines mario lavoie
ça c'est un piège en faisant plus est
les poils du chat dessus
paul ii je connais bien le point de
charme et le raf avait des poils de
chien sur mes 10 cm alors là
non parce qu'en plus la voix mais il ya
quelque chose à voir sauf urgence parce
que c'est dias
bon allez vous
arthur lui au ministère rasant les murs
j'ai bien vu on a trouvé plein c'est
quoi ça servait paul je venais pas non
non on aime bien vous avez raison très
haut rien dans ces personnes très très
bien quand même
il est venu nous voir l'année dernière
mathieu joron surtout monter un peu la
voix de fachos ouais ouais non mais je
ne suis pas d'accord j'ai pas fait sur
une voie très bonne voie pour le voir
c'est connu le dernier le dernier à la
main passé le choc à main wise as les
bureaux de françois
corty je dirais tu ne me même pas rien
[Musique]
c'est le fer de lance
et connaît plus que les groupes
indépendants sa forme c'est d'autre
c'est d'autant plus grave ceux qui sont
chez virgin
c'est grave voici le suivirent james a
désolé je t'aime comme un sens du récit
[Musique]
un ministère je suis à la lettre mais si
tu en as raismes c'est ça oui si si si
si évidemment il est remis leur éternité
m'vila
[Musique]
ouais
j'ai appris que dans des années disons
de 63 72 comme ça tu jouais dans des
dans des groupes de rock plus ou moins
obscurs et que même aujourd'hui cantal
blues battus prend du joue de la guitare
tu dis que ça avec ça vaut mieux que le
psy quoi j'étais préparé un c'est vrai
c'est bizarre chez 17 salles permettent
d'annoncer alors je t'aimerai par un
blind test des groupes de cette épaule
tu es prêt à l'essayer mais bon c'est
avoir la mémoire si la mémoire flanche
[Musique]
réserver
[Applaudissements]
d'accord avec le fait rentrer il
s'appelait c'est la leçon que je
comprenais rien à manger
[Musique]
ouais attend c'est pas les délais
c'est-à-dire bird 6 ouais ben harper
dallest partis à londres la délégation
pour aller voir ailleurs d'autant qu'en
club c'était une époque s'appelait
commenté je n'ai pas su l'aider
les mouettes et après la période noire
blanche est très fort et ça les jeux
suivants
non mais je connais son nom sont tous
dans la merde
et ouais mais jusque là j'aurais pu
faire ça aurait plus sa part à ce rendez
vous dans la ville et où est la
locomotive et le batteur le lendemain à
ce que les blues avaient sainte-adresse
mans où était le pasteur dans l'arène
fait à la répète le batteur tu veux les
cymbales un willy bernard qui suit fait
un taux qu elle était il avait un côté
comme il faisait keith moon bay ou sur
scène à l'époque
ouais ça va lancer dès maintenant il ya
un qui est souvent les cours et c'est
tmc qui joue sa guitare a coûté la vie
hier dans son droit c'était bon suivant
[Musique]
amadou qui dénie tout commentaire
obama c'est un noir qui devait apporter
le novice tout ça c'était pas des potes
c'est pas
[Musique]
or c'est bondé perdre fm affichent-ils
c'est vrai c'est plus dense est vrai
alors c'est anglaise de liverpool
[Musique]
ça me plaisait mais non j'ai envie que
je pense pas qu une pause goûter jus
j'ai du mal à te lui était sûrement pas
sur ce que j'ai le plus de balles lui et
c'est le chanteur ces radars john tu es
le morceau s'échine notaire et je
connais pas à évaluer la future c'est
une chambre ils sont impitoyables mais
là je je sais les zooms mise je connais
pas les ati que les parisiens alors le
soleil soleil se lève là alors c'est
vrai
tarif très jeune comme on a quelques
années ce jour il plante drummond et
kyle le sous-bois québécois puis je vais
pas passer
moi je vous ai mouais mais je clique
s'épanche que j'étais trop dans le mix
et pietro pour faire de la musique c'est
à la musique copier coller à 15 mois
paul de copier et plus tard quand j'ai
arrêté même de jouer en groupe
j'ai commencé je pense jouer devrait
plus avoir un rapport avec la musique
plus intéressant là c'était pareil moi
j'étais fan des beatles était coiffé
pareil j'essayais l'évitement kouchner
qui ont une ps3 est comme folle les
chemins de compenser quand on n'avait
pas beaucoup ces chiens y en avait un il
a l'air vraiment dur et colza
[Musique]
avec ap
je finis la mène pourquoi j'appelle
régions comme en parlait pas des gars là
on n avait autant dire c'est pas le même
jeu c'est pas des morceaux de faire des
bons joueurs qui allaient a fait les
belles chansons on dirait des victoires
a dit cela parce que là pour ce faire
cela on sait que ça c'est dur avec la il
avait scié un peu on disait attention
les beatles
yvonne est un peu d'australie ils ont
fait très peu de 10 au 12 et le nom il
dit
et vous pouvez l'applaudir arrêté
[Musique]
ouais c'est quoi lt reçoit ce soir à dos
c'est un peu plus dur
c'est du bonheur aussi
et puis est même possible chez huawei
c'est pas mon comme on dit me coupe de
thé mais bon il est bien tu vois je
préfère un narcissique et pèse 200
virtuose mais je n'ai jamais été attiré
par les virtuoses il les met le fling
pas fait jouer avec j'adore qu'elle joue
doucement j'ai testé à l'époque tu
aimais bien mac le fais ma vie ce noir
castrats vous savez j'ai eu le coup
comme tout le monde va sonner que le
meilleur alors comme il joue vite aux
afriques ça c'est vrai bon et après pas
plus que ça non un bon film pas ton fils
malade au suivant ça te reconnaître tout
de suite c'est le vent ça s'appelle no
levante samedi s'appellent
[Musique]
gipsy kings ouais ça s'est passé cadre
cette fois que s'inspirer des morceaux
dinh cung en dessous mme way qui a été
repris par l'eau les manuels tubes en
espagne et ont fait une superbe reprise
et puis qui est un peu différente a ici
c'est un morceau que je vais attendre
google tu penses pas les appliquer
j'aime bien moi je trouve que c'est
coûte parce que c'est là c'est la vraie
roue bâle la roma catalan en plus dans
le côté français en plus bon les
espagnols certains faits mais nous y
sommes pas et je trouve ça dommage parce
que c'est en espagne sont considérés
comme par le public très bien fini le
monde tu vas aimer encore certaines un
puriste qui on a moins à casser quoi
mais ça fait partie du fait des coûts
d'aujourd'hui et c'est bien c'est dire
que ce ne sont pas deux derniers disques
est un peu plus faible en qu'on peut
non je sais pas
mais je ne sais pas si c'est vraiment
les compositeurs tu vois je crois que
c'est plus des performeurs un grand
chanteur j'ai un truc sympa ce soit les
compositeurs 0
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais c'est important cela est connu
à l'époque cahier tout moment de gloire
mais aujourd'hui qui peut elle encore
c'est un des fondateurs
des chutes ou suivant
[Musique]
reflets avec qui attend avec quelqu'un
qui chante avec toi tu vas y chante avec
une dame
il a chanté les gars là tony soit mêlé
sa voix
tony donne moi c'est vrai c'est lui qui
m'a vraiment
tu devais n'attise pas colette un set
suivant le dîner kravitz
au début j'étais un peu agacé oui au
début j'ai vu en première fois dans ton
émission qu'on était passé et je
trouvais rigolo mais c'est vrai on s'est
rendu compte que j'ai craqué tout le
monde et qui avait vraiment quelque
chose dedans quand même j'écoute
vraiment facilité en dix grands pas
jeter tout mais c'est moi énervant que
la filière h
moi ce que je me bouge et à franchir sur
l'état adams ouais nouveau fabuleux
titre mais bon lui et côté rock'n'roll
en plus dont on a vraiment besoin d'un
swing abbas à amman en ce moment mais
j'ai entendu l'un en premier a dit paul
qui était vachement bien ouais non
compris je trouvais très rapidement mes
phrases et un seul rock'n roll de
nouveau n'a pas tellement quoi bon moi
je sais que j'ai un capable d'arriver à
cette simplicité de nouveau toit du
maître très simple et y aller quand un
animal c'est dur de redevenir un animal
on essaie de faire mais c'est dur
l'original se sont
hyper en avance la cenap tout ça
moi je n'ai entendu par toi j'ai mis un
moment à savoir ce que c'était le piège
au début je me suis dit [ __ ] qu'est ce
que c'est on les connaît mais tayrac par
m en fait j'avais pas écouté l'original
moi quand j'ai fait j'ai écouté
l'original le jour du mixage
parce que je voulais retrouver un peu le
son des deux doigts de corps décade su
qu'on met l'autre aurait de l'eau et
dont j'ai écouté le jour du mixage et
[Musique]
j'avais tout refait de t'être que de
mémoire pour ça que c'est à ces titres
est très bien c'est rare qu'une reprise
tout aussi bien j'ai dit non c'est vrai
elle le met un site innovant l'applaudir
bravo michel charasse dernière épreuve
relativement facile on ne bouge pas
est-ce qu'on peut baisser la lumière
s'il vous plaît serge khalfon donc vous
faire un petit blind test alors on a
choisi des morceaux qui vous
rappelleront le puy-de-dôme le petit
village dont vous êtes le maire depuis
je vais tout alors je vous demande pas
le nom des chanteurs je vous demandais
que le nom des chansons et on ne souffle
pas didier est ce que tu es prêt
première chance
sable à une thèse des sciences des
canards sur quelque chose comme ça
j'entends ça dans tous les bals à chauny
la chenille centre droit la leader dans
les bus il a dit je te retrouverai la
sorte se retrouvera la soirée
j'en suis pas encore au degré supérieur
penser que c'est pas un séducteur mais
on en est on a choisi ses chansons parce
que c'est ce que vous entendez tous les
week-ends dans le puy-de-dôme
enfin souvent au bal en tout cas
deuxième chanson
[Musique]
ça s'appelle vacances à auchy
vous allez
non
comment s'appelle comment est ce que
quelqu'un siens dada
chanson numéro 3 didier une caresse pour
la connaissance à la légation foot et
dans ses balles et je suis maire je suis
maire de paris je trouve que la moindre
des choses c'est que quand les sociétés
locales font l'effort de faire un bal et
puis en plus difficile parce qu'on a
toujours que malheureusement des
casseurs ou des choses comme ça pour
rien les emplois c'est tout le bader et
comme les hôpitaux les débats la défense
ya parfois des balles en province on
s'amuse beaucoup mieux que dans l'est
dans les bois des soirées parisiennes
voilà ça j'aime bien mon avis et je
confirme je suis en tournée je vais dans
les boîtes de province et j'espère avoir
le plaisir de vous accueillir puis aussi
vrai après une tournée venait échelle
avec bigel vous avez une ouverture à huy
avait dit qu elle dit comme vous j'ai
jamais vu comme ça alors je vous jure
c'est la première fois ensemble on n'est
pas comme s'ils n'en ont pas du tout bon
chanson numéro un et ne cédez jamais
dans ce travail
c'est quoi ça
alors sans son numéro 7 vous deviez s'il
vous plaît
titou lamaison
nous installons saucisses la connaissait
j'entends ça tout le temps
il n'y a pas que ça quand même dans les
bals de promo ya des musiques plus
modernes en chanson numéro huit viviers
site
je
ac le monde
on met la charrue
j'ai bien dit sa passion mon plaisir
d'être avec tous ces chanteurs chanson
numéro 10 didier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais n'est ce pas si mal finalement
on remercie de l'avoir épargnée les
chansons de jeunesse étudiante très bien
michel merci beaucoup on peut allumer la
lumière s'il te plaît
marc lavoine l'heure est venue de nous
démontrer vos connaissances musicales
mon cher ami
c'est tout le monde peut jouer voilà
alors comme bonnes chansons comme si les
tournesols on à faire de la vitesse on a
fait la bd
alors on attend un blind test avec des
chansons tout le monde peut jouer avec
des chansons qui ont des noms de fleurs
ça vous rappelle des souvenirs liés aux
les blind test oui tout petit on
travaille sur une bd chaîne alors
première chanson didier s'il vous plaît
[Applaudissements]
attention à miami d'amos et voilà un
point pour michèle bernier natacha bas
mais non mais attends ça débarque club
la vitesse renault je faisais ce que je
sais que c'est alors françoise hardy
françoise hardy laurent bourgnon sur vos
bateaux vous avez la radio la musique
indispensable à toute la journée vous
écoutez quoi un peu tout un petit cap
bon alors là non mais tout le monde peut
jouer
l'intérêt du brent et s'est trouvée dès
les premières mesures alors 2e deuxième
disque
oui le ton monte l'amour est un bouquet
de violettes va très bien alors
maintenant on passe à la troisième et là
je dois dire que vous avez une avance
considérable
michèle bernier troisième chanson didier
s'il vous plaît magna a répondu la
bassée marché de marseille pour la
suivante ça c'est fascinant c'est
vraiment vous faire
bon
[Applaudissements]
il marchait bien jolie maman elle est
restée très bas et les téléphones et
chanson réaliste
c'est seulement dans ma grand-mère à de
votre grande la porte en chanson
suivante monsieur didier on ne souffle
pas la porte
allez on est sympa on a même eu juillet
la suivante monsieur didier gentil
coquelicot
bravo messieurs regard là si vous
trouvez les deux suivantes
voilà attention monsieur didier tension
[Musique]
et
j'aime bien mon père génial à accueillir
mais qu'enfin nous apprécierons j'aime
la mortagne le bord de la mer et les
bulls la star ac
redonneront quand là franchement ça
s'appelle j'aime pas les rhododendrons
et ccim la suivante en bordure
[Musique]
j'ai rien y sommes c'est dick annegarn
et du futur à ces jeunes gens à
connaître hubert félix thiéfaine gobain
oui oui vous aussi bon et la dernière
chanson attention je pense que tout le
monde
[Applaudissements]
le maire michèle bernier mais je suis
une discothèque moi j'adorais ça je
regardais toutes les émissions guy lux
ce que mon père me les interdisait à oui
c'est d'ailleurs vrai papa poule unique
droite comme marc maintenant des droits
de vote à un travail à la drogue il
voyait rentrée regarder je regardais le
palmarès de la chanson les trucs comme
ça le jeu de la chan a tempêté ces trucs
comme ça je passais mon temps à essayer
de regarder ça doit l'énerver
bon attention didier est ce qu'on est
prêt à vous connaissez le principe du
blind test mais il connaît rien lui à
groland vous connaissez quoi qu'on
reçoit pas là on ne soit pas on n'a pas
du tout les mêmes chaînes de télé chez
nous connaît ma fille connais bien
entendu linda vous connaissez wc high
tech on va vous jouer des chansons
il faut reconnaître que c'est vous vous
êtes très fort en blunt est
mais si il ya une grève il ya un thème
si les animaux c'est parce que l'on ma
fille est ce que peu de gens savent
c'est que laurent baffie 15 au log
émérite et don mischer new marais pas
voir non c'est moi et surtout les gens
du blaye sur tous les animaux qu'il faut
découvrir laurent nous donnera le petit
détail un petit peu comme avec le baume
scène fait une chanson française les
jeunes les internationaux il ya beaucoup
de chansons françaises merde qu'on l'a
commencée didier premières chansons
attention le premier gala
[Musique]
le
non non
dans le nord
alors quand il une lola la blesse
évident que la chanson s'appelle le loup
le renard
j'étais inquiète inquiète l'ani des
canidés mustélidés juste et l'idée c'est
la belette la belette est un must et
good way et quelles sont les
particularités du mustélidés lourdes un
animal un petit un petit carnivore qui
est très très courant dans l'hexagone
beaucoup de représentants on a la chance
de l'apercevoir maintenant aux portes de
paris j'ai vu j'ai un blaireau l'audio
facile parce qu'ils les troupes y attend
celle ci arrive quasi la nuit six fléaux
la paie à l'appui et une pile à 6 heures
du matin au smoking vraiment super bien
on continue c'est beaucoup plus
difficile deuxième chanson didier ansa
il faut être fou à voir là je tapais
femme se mettre très très dur à
reconnaître ou sans papiers bravo à
l'aller jeudi restent ouverts
[Musique]
lizzy mercier descloux sont passées les
gazelles les fréquentent jamais
merci didier bon alors là on a pris un
point
nous voyons un point répondants linda
mais moi je regarde vos fiches donc
c'est à dire que je ne m'étais cette
énergie incroyable viendrait bien
qu'eric la gazelle est un art you
d'actifs de la famille des bovidés
mais c'est la famille des bonnes idées
la gazelle oui et c'est en quoi un art
you dactyle c'est le contraire de perry
sow dactyle qu'elle a un chiffre impair
deux doigts de la devedjian et change la
vie sur toi là tu es la fuite en
réparant cette espèce et il est quoi une
place que depuis le début de la soirée
il te prenais pour un mustélidés est
malade un coup il dit ce gars là est
vachement savant didier troisième
morceau c'est pour nous et ça j'aime
bien et alors
bravo
restaurant
je laisse tomber
et un large sourire et chaussé de bottes
les 13 hommes sa boîte de nuit envie
d'entamer non monsieur monsieur on est
passé j'ai dit tu t'arrêtes l'ordre
quitté qu'il est tout simplement comme
moi didier s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
e
et du cacao
la motion moustiques
alors didier comme on est en retard la
loue en ce moment c'est moins bien qu'en
didier qu'on est en retard tu sautes le
morceau suivant et tu vas au suivant je
me retiens leurs quarante familles des
quartiers cartilagineux assez des
quartiers nations ils ont un squelette
mou ils ont un squelette mois et la rai
la chimère font partie de la même
famille la chimère c'est quoi la c1 une
sorte de poisson fait partie de la
famille des quartiers là j'ai une
famille des balladuriens et si le
balladuriens cartilagineux bon on saute
le morceau suivant
didier tension
[Musique]
non pas du tout ils ont enfin demandé la
terre
la maison j'ai passé
la musique et les cascio n'être que sa
vie ses missions suivantes signé
et en toile
si les bains mystiques on le sait très
bien vous avez été très bon l'éléphant
ya rien à dire
finnair proboscidiens la gestation de la
maman éléphant je crois que c'est selon
lui
ces 22 moins de deux mois sur la
gestation je prends juste la suite est
pas fort en gestation en production chez
59 ans qui commence à te prendre
mustélidés tu veux savoir
bon dernier morceau le bonus track mais
qui se bat pour reconnaître juste pour
le plaisir d'écouter
[Musique]
jamais
waouh
[Musique]
jb le personnes ont été internées
remercie alors le résultat je dois venir
pensez-vous jules-edouard aller aux jo
je pense prix cassé le loup vient en mai
lui connaissait tous mais souvenez pas
des notes
[Musique]